in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about mutations and i want to
apologize ahead of time my voice is a
little strange today i rode more roller
coasters than i thought i would
yesterday and i screamed a little bit
but anyway
what we see right over here is
what's often known as the central dogma
of biology it explains how we go from
information in our dna which is really
sequences of nucleotides genes are
segments of our dna that code for
specific things so we see these
nucleotides which we denote with a c g's
and t's
and every three of them that's known as
a codon and for every three of them it's
associated with an amino acid and in
other future parts of your biology
education you'll go into more depth on
the molecular structures of amino acids
but what you need to know now is the
amino acids are essentially strung
together and then they create proteins
and proteins have all sorts of functions
in your body to a large degree they make
you you they construct what you are
so this is a simplified version of how
we go from dna to
you
to some degree
now mutations as you might know even
when you watch some movies these are
changes in dna you might have seen
superheroes be exposed to radiation or
some type of chemical and then they get
mutations and all of a sudden they have
powers
well we don't know about too many
mutations that create the ability to fly
or to stick to walls
but mutations are a way that we get new
genetic information in the gene pool
now you might be saying wait i already
know about sexual reproduction sexual
reproduction creates variation and
that's true sexual reproduction creates
variation but it really just shuffles
around the genes and the chromosomes
thereon that exist already inside of a
gene pool
mutations are actually changes in the
genes
now where do these mutations come from
well there are sometimes errors when dna
is copied but can also happen from
environmental influences like radiation
or other things now as you can imagine
many times if you were to just all of a
sudden eliminate some nucleotides or if
you were to change them into something
else
that might be harmful all of a sudden it
might code for an amino acid here that
does not allow this protein to function
properly
sometimes it can be beneficial and
that's how we can get new versions of
genes alleles or new genes all together
all of a sudden this became that this
becomes a different amino acid maybe
this protein functions better
and then as you can imagine sometimes it
doesn't matter at all maybe the
different amino acid here really doesn't
change the structure of this protein and
in some cases you can even change the
nucleotide and it still codes for the
same amino acid